Star Trek Prodigy still might get saved
not just for the season two that they're
already making
but somebody might be about to order
season three two
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
so when Paramount plus announced that it
was not only removing season one of Star
Trek Prodigy from Paramount plus but
also that they would not be showing
season two there was it's fair to say
Opera a lot of Star Trek fans went
absolutely nuts now a lot of people
didn't actually see Star Trek Prodigy it
was a kid's cartoon so why bother but
I've actually been arguing since I did
finally get around to watching it that
this is actually one of the most tracked
shows that we've actually had really
during this whole period of new track
[Music]
Grace for impact
thank you
they did it yes it's animated yes it's
aimed at kids yes it's irritating in
places because it's aimed at kids but
actually from like a Gene Roddenberry
point of view Like a Star Trek point of
view it's one of the most tricky things
we've had and it had Big Star Trek
moments in it like the destruction of
the Enterprise E
so the fact that people didn't watch it
confused me
I would have thought trekkies would eat
it up and to be honest it was really
heartwarming to see the reaction when
Paramount plus did make its announcement
they put out a petition immediately on
change.org and it's had over 32 000
signatures now that's actually more
signatures than the strange new worlds
petition had that you know Paramount
made such a fuss about you know
delivering what we want to the fans and
all that so in theory Powerman should
listen again right well they did
announce almost a media actually the
Star Trek Prodigy was not canceled they
were not going to be shown on Paramount
plus but they were looking for somebody
else to buy it now previously a lot of
Star Trek has been done in partnership
with other production companies to save
costs for example the first two seasons
of Picard were only on initially at
least Amazon Prime
the third season was Amazon Prime as
well but the day after it premiered on
Paramount plus lower decks has always
been on Amazon Prime as well even though
now that is also moving to Paramount
plus as well in the last two years you
see Paramount has been trying to move
Star Trek back to Paramount plus because
Star Trek is considered the jewel in the
crown over there
but fortunately though more recently the
reality has started to bite Paramount
plus subscriptions has not been as
successful as they'd hoped they really
hoped that people would follow Star Trek
to it they didn't at least not in the
numbers they'd hoped so how am I trying
to go back to that original formula of
trying to sell TV products like Star
Trek Prodigy to other stream and
services to just generate a bit of
income and it looks like Star Trek
Prodigy has found that streaming
provider now producers have actually
already admitted this they've already
said the conversations have happened and
those conversations had been fruitful
but we didn't know who they were talking
to well thanks to sources I have in an
array of Paramount it turns out that
those people are Amazon Prime now when
Star Trek probably was actually removed
from Paramount plus it did appear on
Prime behind a paywall so you could pay
for it to rent it but it wasn't a
available on Prime generally for anyone
to watch
I'm hearing though that conversations
are continuing and negotiations are
happening right now but more than just
taking on season two apparently Amazon
are already talking to Paramount about
ordering a third season Amazon have been
very happy with the numbers they've been
getting from people purchasing the first
season of Prodigy and actually believe
they can have another really good
animated series on their hands so
they're very keen to actually not just
take the show on because the season two
has already virtually been made but to
actually go beyond that and make more
Prodigy now if this actually comes off I
think a lot of Star Trek fans are going
to be seriously excited about this I
personally hope that Amazon sort of
changed the tone slightly of Star Trek
Prodigy moving forward to make it a
slightly more grown-up animated series
I'm the doctor an emergency medical
holographic program and dear friend of
the Admiral member of the Voyager crew
hero of the Delta quadrant
but even if they don't to be honest what
we got from the first season
particularly the last couple of episodes
of the first season were
quite excellent
It's Voyager but not like Jacob's ever
seen it her predecessor is a floating
Museum so Janeway thought it was high
time for an upgrade so we have to wait
and see what happens but my source is
telling me that those negotiations are
still moving forward and basically it's
really just a sticking point on money
right now but as soon as those contracts
are realized and finalized we could get
Star Trek season 2 of Prodigy on Amazon
very very quickly followed by the
announcement that we're also going to be
getting a season three so guys get into
the comments and tell me what you think
have you seen Star Trek Prodigy yet do
you understand the excitement that
basically a lot of trekkies have and why
they got so upset when Paramount made
the decision that they did but also what
do you think about the plans for a
season three is that as exciting to you
as it is to me because I love this show
I actually think the animated stuff
currently is the only good track coming
out of sort of the kurtzman era I think
it's way better than a strange new
worlds even I can't wait for more
prodigy but what do you think get into
the comments if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification you know what to do
and also you can go to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where most of
our new videos appear first and for
small contribution each month and you
can get a free gift you get to see those
videos without the adverts and before
everyone else
also you can go to sidetrack.co.uk which
is our dedicated Sidetrack website where
stories from most of our videos appear
and you get a little bit of extra
content so please go over and check that
out
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]